what's going on there citizens of the
reject nation i'm miguel i am
robbie
good job andrew good job doing it hawks
crier all right
like cut it out hawk
say hi to the audience hey guys what's
going on a positive energy hey everyone
very popular being weird
that's how miguel talks
nailed my impression
did you say mary poppins was he cool
yeah he was i'm mary poppins y'all this
is a great great final episode intro
today all right guys
we're at the finale of cobra kai
andrew's going to bring his a game with
listening all the easter eggs he won't
miss a single one and if he does you
make sure to give him crap in the
comments give him hell
leave a like that'd be very much
appreciated also full length reaction
watch alongs where you sync up with your
own copy for cobra kai all that's over
at our patreon page for super sexy
rejects the prepper team help us edit
down these highlights
namaste
[Music]
every memory of me
will be erased
says who
the best student i ever had
was like a son to me
so keep fighting
but with your heart and soul
instead of your fists
that's enough this piece of shit's
asking for it
let it go
whoa
is this really happening right now
whoa
i don't believe it
oh
he did
[Music]
no
oh my god i can't believe that just
happened
mike barnes no
my life was fine before you showed up
next thing i know there's a pile of
ashes where my store was that place was
leveraged to the hill daniel i'm broke
my wife
i had to give them my wife
my wife this guy
just destroys people's lives bit by bit
and he never faces any consequences you
know what i see
i see four consequences right here
i'm gonna go over there and beat the
living [ __ ] out of him yes i like the
way this guy thinks
help me out here this is crazy
i know silver's on us
jesus christ we're not gonna ride for
justice like some party limo posse suit
yourself
mike
are you kidding me
please tell me he has this vote i know
if the attack happened at the old dojo
that would have been after silver
installed the new security cameras so
maybe it's all caught on tape no but
that place was cleaned out that might
not matter
i mean the systems that we sell at tech
town all save the footage to a central
circle it's tied together
if we get access to it we could
definitely find that footage we could
even post that stingray clip to their
youtube channel get a hold of everyone
else
let them know that we're taking down
cobra kai
tonight
evil dies tonight
i understood that reference we'll send
them a message well before the
tournament
when and how to deliver it exactly
i don't know yet
but it won't be subtle
oh my god oh my it's been a long
time oh i'd say you're keeping well but
all evidence to the contrary that's what
happens when someone burns your life to
the ground oh my what a crime
[ __ ] it's called trespassing which
means
any violence inflicted upon you herein
will be justified
oh my god they all sleep there i'm gonna
knock his ass out
and then you're next
that was short-lived daniel where are
you i have no idea i am stranded in the
middle
i have terrible service out here i just
i just need you to come and get me all
right i'm dropping you a pin
amanda
what oh god no
someone's here what who
they're parking in our driveway it's
cobra kai what
is it stingray would you upload the clip
to the youtube channel and cobra kai is
out of business for good
okay stories assault happened the
morning after prom
any idea how to disconnect one of these
yeah
yeah kick it
in all of our faces easy money
they're hitting us on two fronts
take care i'll join you there as soon as
i wrap things up here
yeah yeah dude chosen oh
johnny oh my god chosen versus terry
you're the first person i've seen in
miles
and i gotta get home now and this truck
is gonna take me there one way or the
other
oh oh [ __ ]
[Music]
run them over stingray
mr larusso
come with me if you want to live
yes it's from toro rico right
end of days andrew ah i like that movie
i got it
you ought to be covered oh my god they
do have it
uh
what happened
that's all there is i think there might
be some other footage we can use you
wouldn't have another date and time
would you
yeah that's the one guys what you're
doing what's that hey
we'll go check it out you guys stay here
we need that footage
what's your test
i don't know
mitch come on get your ass over here
where you belong
oh
yeah i knew it oh [ __ ] you traitor
silverlight
to all of us us the only person who lied
to me is you hey robbie's right
you don't want to do this
yeah i do
god i got that group text from the cobra
kais saying they were going to ambush
your students i i knew i had to step in
and warn you we just have to get to the
kids before someone gets hurt we will
what are you doing it's pitch blackout
stingray seem better in the dark
is this a manual car
yes come on
the fight we've all been waiting for you
will beg for mercy
right
it's time to find out
oh here we go people good
because he's drunk
oh yeah
yeah there's a good sensor
nicely
done but now
time to find out what you're really made
of
i'm not afraid to kill
oh my god i can't believe it's rafael vs
leonardo
look at him just confidently walking
[Music]
[Music]
not bad
[Music]
oh
jesus
let's just go way real
woohoo
[Music]
[Music]
god damn come on chosen
[Music]
it's not cool
blood in the water
[Music]
i was meant to die
and about
do it
no no
no
prick psycho
prick
you don't want to be on their side trust
me like you trusted me
you've been lying about who said you
were really on this whole time i know
i'm sorry i tried telling you
they're coming be ready to go mobile
okay screw it up we're gonna have to
upload and publish via wi-fi
i understand these problems very well
yeah you heard kenny when he dropped
your ass just a faux hawk now boy
you know what
that's life
you win some you lose some but you got
to move on you never did you're still
playing the same old bully act as always
even though everyone you bullied has
kicked your ass by now
kyle's too stupid to ever learn his
lesson
[Music]
yes hawk
come on robbie
oh yeah here we go and a conversoby one
i'm not your enemy
jesus
attacking me
my
you never stood a chance if it's any
consolation
at least you won't be around to screw up
another kid
[Laughter]
oh jesus
yeah dimitri yeah oh my god he's
handling the whole thing
he got his turn
we got it all right it's uploading the
cobra guy's channel let's get the hell
out of here
binary bros
protect that ipad for the love of christ
[Music]
oh sensei kim let this be my final
lesson to you then and a more painful
one than the last
miguel we got it
don't step on it
oh no
protect the egg
oh yeah
come on
take advantage
devin help her
oh sam i guess
ouch
[Music]
come on devin
you can be a champion do not throw that
away
oh i will be a champion but i'll get
there my way
not yours
go save your brother we've got this
mvp
i'll take this trash out
come on give him a cool moment
give him a cool moment
[Music]
[Applause]
30
oh my god so close
longer there's too many legs
oh i think i deal with the process
anytime
just standard definition that's all we
need
nickels
what's on your mind
excited to take things to the next level
oh yeah you'll just pay to make me
champion again
have you told anyone else
not yet
see him tonight not at all
i paid him off to make sure cobra guy
won that's great audio
there's a boom mic on that security
camera that was your big plan larusso
breaking into my dojo
to steal some footage that changes
nothing
oh no they're gonna fire
rematch
and what does the enemy deserve
come on danny crane kick him they hear
you but they don't listen
life isn't a fairy tale it's a
competitive sport
right and wrong there's no such thing
there are only winners
and losers
geez
cobra kai no winners because we're
willing to do whatever it takes to come
out on top fight four
yeah exactly
[Music]
[Music]
another eye patch
oh
oh [ __ ]
dude where the hell is mike barnes
you're like two seconds
[Applause]
or mike barnes stun double you know
is where miyagi doe
ends
it'll be around long after we're gone
the roots are strong
so the tree will survive
[Music]
nice work daniel [ __ ] slap craig
it comes in two parts and has three
rules i call it quick silver quicksilver
[Music]
rule number one
a man can't stand he can't fight
break it
[Laughter]
[Music]
a man can't breathe
he can't fight
oh i got so many nipple chills right now
cheater
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
nothing will ever be more satisfying
than this moment
crying kick point
the ref's gonna be like no point
do the right thing boss
we're gonna go be [ __ ] somewhere
else is this yours
supposed to be yours but uh but i broke
up with you before you could give it to
me
i think that that just seemed like it
was more important means a lot to me
that's what you do when you love someone
right
never said that before
i do
i love you too
oh
yay
thought of losing you and miguel and
robbie and her family
kicked me into a gear i didn't know i
had
couldn't stand the thought of missing
out on the rest of our life together
i can't believe we got the crane kick
still on the roof
[Laughter]
come on
take you to the goddamn hot this man has
lost so much blood
a real war tonight
never thought i'd see the day when
silver was finally in handcuffs what
about craig
all right larissa i finally took silver
out no more looking over our shoulders
at every turn right
here's helping silver and crease end up
cell mates
you mean john crease oh no
you didn't hear what happened oh
did he break out was this like a ploy to
break out oh my god
that's what i was thinking at the very
top but i was like maybe not stop in a
fight he got what he deserved
yeah yeah
it's jello yep this is melted jello
oh oh my god
crap
i'm begging you
for what
mercy mercy if you just waited like five
minutes
oh my you would have got it out
perfectly fine
my friend
you told me you've been fighting all
your life
so keep fighting
[Music]
chris lives
oh
and to think i felt bad for you
[Music]
no we gotta wait another season ah
i can't wait
i can't do it
i can't i had a i had a feel at the very
beginning i was like maybe but it was
like that guy turned on pretty
yeah yeah yeah his buddy and i was like
he looks pale but maybe they're just
doing that to mislead us with the
lighting he just held his breath really
good and that jello came out very
convincingly too
i know
we're gonna do
oh that was great that was all right
john take it away that was a very uh
intense and emotional finale and i am
very very much satisfied in this moment
uh
oh man
uh the way everything has come to a head
i think it's it's usually a good sign
when you end the season on a note of
like man they threw everything at this
and aside from the fact that kris is you
know coming back you're like i don't
know
where we go from here exactly especially
with cobra kai
whatever it is at least losing this crop
of students and whatnot you know they'll
find a way back in but yeah i thought
this this built
really nicely out of the previous
episode and gave you so many
knuckle
you know white knuckle nail biting
moments
just like the i'll you know just go
around the litany of fights you know
first with
everybody busting in on terry silver and
then uh you know all the solo fights
within like you got a a lot of fan like
a a lot of like really not fan
fulfillment per se but it's like you get
to see chosen fight terry you can see
danny fight terry you can see johnny
take on a whole bunch of dudes
and uh you get to see all the kids kind
of bring everything to a head like this
just had
so much and also felt like just the
right amount
and uh
yeah like
my hair's blown back a little bit like
the way they've been able to keep this
show building and growing
and
again skating on that line of it could
always be just a little too much but
never fully falling there i thought the
whole thing making it mike who
intervenes on them and the limo was a
good call because it pays that off you
get a little bit more with him even
though he doesn't steal the focus and
it's not like okay like you know you're
set up to think like terry silver is
just omnipotent
um but i thought that was a nice
curveball to kind of bring everything
back around and the whole mess of like
we didn't tell the kids to break in and
we're doing this thing over at silver's
house and now we're all kind of meeting
in the same place like i thought they
they orchestrated all that chaos in a
really
fine way
and i feel like in you know less skilled
hands it could have just felt like chaos
uh but no it was very palpable and very
vital even though chaotic so yeah i'm
i can't say enough but i don't want to
take command of the entire review
so keep going so yeah what is no let's
let's hear some eggs first oh some share
the mic some eggs you mean like uh mike
like trader joe's 329 329. yeah yeah
frozen spent a lot of money that day all
right well let's see let's see what i
can pull out that's way too many wait a
minute
that should not be overlooked what you
just did there
that was really well done
thank you thank you i appreciate easter
eggs referring to easter eggs and then
you said 329 bringing it back to a
referencing conference i know i did
something impressive it was very good
it's giving me a pat on the back so
thank you very much
thank you thank you all right let's see
what we got in this episode 29 you son
of a [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's really good i try
i try uh at the beginning of the episode
they called mike barnes the bad boy
that's what he was referenced as in
karate kid part three we got uh michael
beans kyle reese aka stingray saying uh
come with me if you want to live
obviously that line was also
regurgitated by the t-800 again at
pescadero hospital and uh t2 judgment
day where he said to sarah connor the
same thing we also got terry silver
being uh crane kicked into the mirror
and breaking it mr miyagi threw him into
the mirror where the paint
fell down onto him that was karate kid
part three we got that flashback of
course from karate kid part three
and
yeah i'm sure there are many others i am
missing too but those are just the ones
that come off of hand in regards to this
episode this whole episode was a tribute
to uh the legend of drunken master
obviously oh for sure
because they were all drunk yeah
and uh yeah no in regards to this
episode um
wow uh the hand-to-hand choreography
just it really is amazing just every
season they always seem to up the ante
and this season just or this finale held
no punches i mean i if you guys would
have told me before the episode that we
were going to see someone's finger be
sliced off and then actually like pic
literally focus on that shot seeing the
blood come out and then
you know the finger there i would say no
that's too graphically violent for
cobra kai or something from karate kid i
i just don't see that but no they pulled
no punches metaphorically speaking when
it came to this episode but the show was
not family friendly yeah no i mean
there were two f words in this episode
so yeah definitely uh but no this finale
was amazing it was emotional it was
violent it was great i just i feel so
bad for my boy terry silver i mean he's
just the kind of guy that he feels he's
the kind of guy he's the kind of guy we
all look up to and we all want to be at
least
you know money-wise at least but uh i
mean no he's the hero yeah he is the
hero look i'm cobra guy all the way i
didn't take my shirt off at the end guys
no but this finale was was oh another
reference i just remembered is when the
tv fell down uh when they were fighting
that was a trope that happened in the
first three seasons in the first uh
the second season it happened when
daniel kicked johnny in the first season
it happened when johnny threw the beer
can or the beer glass into the tv when
uh daniel's commercial was on uh for
larusso otto and then the third one when
carmen and johnny were about to make
love and they knocked over the tv so it
was a trophy thing that happened where
the tv was always falling down so dude
also johnny used to hang tvs but now
he's knocking him down that's true very
true
very true but yeah this was a this was a
great finale and just again we could
have gotten so lost with all these
fights and it's like all right this is
just i think john pointed out best like
you know
sometimes there is a limit to okay
they're just doing too much of a good
thing but this show is so as mr miyagi
would say so well balanced and they just
always know when to hit the right level
of that and
you know from where they were showing
you know the fight with mike barnes and
johnny and chosen versus terry versus
and then with daniel and then the kids
of cobra kai and miyagi fang it just and
then we also got the the storyline with
dimitri and eli with the i mean it all
could have been lost in the shuffle but
they do such a good job of literally
balancing it all out in the proper way
was so well edited and i just all the
the the fight choreography was so well
done i mean you really feel like these
it felt so intense too like all these
punches and that one move that daniel
did where he did that block was so sick
i know you said the crane move was
satisfying which i agreed very
satisfying but that block i have been
demanding the crane kick yeah daniel
showed up but yeah
i know there were just so many great
story lines this entire season i'm
really you know it's like john sam
really curious to see where they go from
here because if you literally stopped
the show right now i mean i would i
would be sad for sure but i think like
this literally would be a perfect ending
if they ended it right here but i'm glad
they're not going to i want them to keep
continuing on but this was literally the
definition of a finale to me and i mean
they wrapped up so many different story
lines so i am very curious where they
are going to go from here you know
especially with cobra kai i mean because
obviously terry's now going to prison or
jail prison whatever and maybe maybe not
i feel like he's a trump metaphor isn't
he isn't he a big metaphor for donald
trump
yeah there you go i just wanted to get
the dislikes going by uh
making it political when it wasn't
yes
well observed
he's donald trump and
danny's biden
the karate version
these are the karate versions of these
characters
you should go and uh you know
deep fake those heads onto those bodies
but i'm also glad to the storyline uh as
well that wrapped up in terms of miguel
and sam i mean that's a really i i don't
know if i'm on the oh kind of on the
miniature here in terms of just thinking
this but i really love that relationship
their character interactions their
on-screen chemistry is just it's so
emotional and so they're so good
together i love watching those too and
just to see the way it paid off in the
end just how how it uh you know finished
off i i really loved watching those two
and
just how it uh finished off i i loved
that uh that ending and their
interactions are so good that was great
i don't think you're on the miniature on
that one man no a lot of people love i'm
with you
miguel scissorhands and sam
none of you guys name dropped tori bunch
of sexist prix food i was happy i loved
her story line this season too it was
really good yeah and they did a they i
think they've done a nice job of making
that feel natural the way they like
robbie's with tory but miguel there's
like there's that crossing of things and
then no but they wind up where they
should yeah and this season was also too
i really like the the theme of like
rekindling friendships or like making
your mortal energy like being friends
with that person now i thought they did
a good job really nailing that down the
season because it could have been like
ah that's really trophy that's formulaic
like i don't buy that they're now
friends like now they actually did it in
a way that felt satisfying you know from
a story point of view as well as an
emotional beating i felt like it they
they literally landed the kicks with
those uh emotional beats no pun intended
but yeah those were really well done in
the season when it came to miguel and
robbie and tori and sam and i guess you
could say tori and devin as well i
really thought those were well done so
and i think my favorite though
partnership sorry i know i'm giving you
so much to talk about i think my
favorite thing to watch this season
though besides terry obviously chosen
and johnny i love those two together it
is so much fun to watch that you can
tell they're having so much fun uh when
they're working together uh just in
general when they're working on the show
but together they're so much fun to
watch i love we need to we need a
spin-off show just those two
i'm petitioning for it
i'm going to start at change.org for
that
cobra kai presents johnny and chosen
crank kick
chris guys left me to talk with crane
kick
when he did the crane kick it was really
satisfying it was super satisfying that
crane kick
all right
don't worry guys i got plenty to talk
about here
anthony anthony we left you anthony
thank you
dimitrine
um it's they could always pick and
choose where they keep the focus of the
season i think bringing it back to the
center because like the first season is
really just johnny and danny like what
and introducing the
new characters right
uh like miguel it felt like it was
johnny danny miguel and robbie like
those are the main ones and then
yeah those five but it was like johnny
and danny were the main ones
and this ensemble's gone so big so you
have to do focus per season of like who
are we gonna focus on and i thought it
was interesting that
they really gave it to the adults this
time like so much focus was especially
when i think about the last season was
on the kids and tournament and hawk
fighting and sam fighting and everything
you know like it felt like we got our
obligatory big crowd fight with the kids
at the cobra guy cobra kai dojo
and it it was something that i was like
oh yeah i guess you got to have that
but i was really feeling like you know
it's just i kind of had a moment of this
season has been way more about the
the the main adults specifically for
danny like this in some ways this felt
like this was more
central about danny than usual if you
really think about it because like
amanda came around to
understanding and supporting him on
these conquests and the traumas that
he's had to deal with and why he
gets so obsessed with solving the issues
of
the the the vermin that is cobra kai
and you know having chosen in his corner
and johnny come around they all came
around to support me i'll go maggie doe
on this journey and then a client then
it
climaxes with
terry versus danny you know it's like
those two those two figures it really
was a danny versus terry season with a
lot in between of that you know
and uh i really appreciate that they
kept the focus on that as and then you
explore other stories in between there
so yeah you got all the great fights in
here and like chosen i think as a
standout for me this season because
he got a little bit in last season oh no
two seasons ago he got a little bit and
he got like a moment a cameo at the end
of last season and
it really took advantage of having him
here and they they gave him a lot of
nuance and i love that johnny had the
opportunity to
get to know chosen and get to meet mike
barnes at the end like two people is
like who are you who are you because if
johnny definitely felt like a supporting
character this season versus being a
lead and that's okay like that's okay
because whenever he was there he really
stood out and didn't feel like he was
pushed to the background you know like
there's a difference there and you you
do have to keep the focus uh very
specific i did
because the kids didn't feel as like
robbie and danny robbie and miguel had
their arc a little bit earlier in the
middle of the season
whereas for the most part robbie's been
like mister understanding this season
you know other than my little feud i
have with uh miguel you know i'm pretty
misunderstanding this is the last
episode yeah when you leave
you're mistreated yeah you're mr z he
had as he has up and downs with tori and
stuff in the beginning but it could have
felt repetitive it was all about the
kids versus the kids all over again
and so they really did make it about the
adults and like this crazier
uh version of like bringing in these
senses and [ __ ]
so so graphic novelty an 80s action
movie i love it it's just so it's so
hiding it's so wild and i think what
they did with tori of going off of last
season was was one of the more
compelling parts because her whole
identity and her worth had come from
karate and that's all been shattered
and it i like how it doesn't end with
they're all joining miyagi dough it's
like they all don't have a home right
now it could be miyagi dough but we
we really just don't know and it
and i think the way they toured with us
on crease was fun
because he kept having you go chris is
going to be good is he going to change
is he going to learn he just doesn't
no
because he just accepts more of who he
really is at the end of the day and uh
i love that i do i do love the choices
they made i'm kind of just recapping the
season right now because
all the specifics are gone from this
episode
um mike barnes was good
and
uh
guys give me some throw me a bone here
hillary swank yeah you're gonna see her
now you show up [ __ ] [ __ ]
i hate her now she's gonna ride in on
angel from next crowded kid they're
gonna she's gonna die
the real hillary swank i feel like she's
too good for this show maybe what have
you been doing p.s i love you you've
been up to nothing
how old does that mean
it's like 12 years that's my point yeah
what else you've done what are you doing
now you got time netflix show that went
nowhere part of the netflix team come on
next season we got jackie chan we got
jaden smith we got hillary swank they're
all coming in make it all happen
true that
the cobra kai universe got stingray
doctor strange talking about stingray
i asked stingray oh yeah he had that
great moment that was awesome he got to
kick some kid's asses because he
actually got to kick
that moment he did well he had that one
moment to in the school fight at the end
of season two or he was kicking some ass
too but yeah no no no but this was like
this is way better for
something positive yeah
um
but yeah i think the way this all art
overall was was really solid and strong
and
it did it does get you to the point of
like
i want to see terry silver be torn down
yeah you want the truth to come out
because he just keeps winning and i
think when you can get
an audience to that point i think is
very very strong
and i i wanted to see him crumble and
you do and i like that it's more than
just if you watch god bleed if you see
god plead it wasn't that it was you just
got to see him lie and lose to miyakedo
just admit you want to see the jew taken
down it's all good greg is he jewish
don't you remember the episode with him
and sensei rosenthal when he took over
to panga karate they said remember at uh
services this was not the agreement we
made
oh
well
come on man pay attention
yeah how do we hurt the terry didn't
only go to those services just to talk
to sensei rosenthal and they never went
again
or before
what is the next season gonna be it's
always been a very clear setup
for what they want to do that's true
though this is the first time it ends
for
i don't know what this direction that's
why i literally said if again i i'm glad
they're still gonna continue on because
these guys are so good at what they do
the writers and the creators of the show
but i really have no idea where the
direction's gonna go from here but are
they gonna go to that tournament
they have to yeah
but the question because they have to go
crease is going to lead cobra cut but
he's uh kind of like wanted for assault
now
yeah escaping from his hand yeah so i'm
like what is that he's a fugitive yeah
so part of me thinks to myself i'm like
okay well so it would seem as though
danny and then and at least miyagi doe
would go to the sakai taikai but at the
same time i'm like but you know they
don't have the same amount to prove
there i mean you know they could still
prove their point but there has to be
the conflict between them and cobra kai
and with
cobra kai's future uncertain i am like
yeah what is it is it just going to be
about crease literally just assaulting
them between any sort of official karate
like no official karate kobrikai
anything and just crease trying to
assault them or i see it now tommy lee
jones is going to be a u.s deputy and
he's going to be chasing
concrete turf i think they could wrap up
the show next season i think you got to
end on a high note i think they could
wrap it up next season and then do my
spin-off idea
karate kid presents
i know you guys would watch i would
watch that show
joseph and johnny johnny goes to okinawa
i'm watching that well i think johnny
would grow up and i mean he would have
like a family now i could be a father be
it be an actual father maybe run a good
dojo and the kids would probably go to
college right you know and fight
everybody
like
i think i think next season would be a
good time to to wrap up the show because
you could end on a really strong note
and then you get your hillary swing
spin-off season yeah
next season we're going to shoot a whole
new cast
right here or rotary swank is going to
start our own doge
that's that interesting position because
right now part of me because the show
has reached this point without many
missteps i'm like oh
like i i trust the team who makes it to
surprise us with something and it makes
me glad that they didn't pull any
punches in this uh ending of this season
but it does also get me sort of like
worried like oh man like they gotta
really come up with something great and
i bet they probably know already because
then they green light these two these
five and six at the same time
i believe
at the same time oh that's why that's
why we got four in january and five and
september like those are really less
than a year you get the next season
which is very
not usual no it's fast because you have
to shoot and edit oh
yeah
and to keep the quality up to par is
exceptionally impressive that they did
that well they did that with matrix two
and three so yeah and pirates two and
three as well so
yeah i i think i think that next season
that you know i wouldn't be like upset
if they announced it and it's not like
all right you guys are done i just think
it would be a good time to actually hand
it through it'd be bittersweet i like
i prefer bittersweet i like when shows
end when i don't really want them to end
but it makes sense that it would end
because
it would it's better to end on a on a
strong note than like all right i'm
ready for the show to go you know what
greg is saying is he loved that
smallville had 10 seasons
well and you could wait you could wait a
little time even if it doesn't go away
forever you could wait for a few years
until you really get a reason to
surprise us with karate uh cobra kai
karate kid again yeah because uh you
know you could wrap i feel like chris
needs to really really wants to make
real amends with johnny i feel like
that's a
genuine thing i feel like it's a little
more gray at the end
than what was led on and um you know
it's if co if cobra kai is done for
danny could actually bury the past yeah
and live his life yeah you know amanda
would like that yeah so i i think it has
to get to a point where these guys are
ready to move on and um
and and i would be okay for the
characters and i think they could make
something that's complete and beautiful
with promises like you know the netflix
actors don't really get residual checks
that's messed up
yeah that is like the messed up part
like no one really gets residuals on
streaming shows oh no i didn't know that
um yeah it's a real problem i mean i
don't know if it's like that case for
everyone i'm not wrong about that right
i believe that's a real problem i think
that is a thing it's a real issue that's
rest it's been spoken about yeah it
might not i might just not be up to date
i know that was a problem
um i don't know if they've solved that
problem if that is true still that sucks
yeah no it's it is because it's like how
do you factor in paying for something
you know yeah totally it's like on a
voluntary stream basis yeah um and this
doesn't get like actual tv airplay so
yeah no syndication yeah
so yeah um i do think just just a stray
final observation it's so cool and nice
to see an actual sci fight
there are two weapons and all of martial
arts things that i see often where i'm
like oh cool and they almost always go
to a joke and it's psy and nunchucks and
so they actually had a badass sci fight
and two i thought in the show it's
taking so long to get to weapons and
you're in that scene going okay well
this is cool but it's getting kind of
ridiculous and then to bring in that
extra layer of like oh no people are
actually getting sliced up i thought
that really like contributed to like the
danger factor where you're like oh this
is getting really out of hand and two
they they made a crack in one of the
fights about like wait your turn but i
thought especially too this had some of
the best fights for the adult characters
in this episode because like the speed
and the choreography was like super on
point i know we've talked about
sometimes like the young the younger
cast fights always look pretty fast and
pretty you know good
and some of the older characters fights
sometimes can be put in editing uh but
this all around like the fights
there were a couple times in the fight
between silver and chosen i could tell
there was a stunt guy for chosen but i
didn't care i was so invested in the
hair on the left yeah i i did not care i
i was so invested in the fight i think
also all these fights throughout all the
seasons especially in the final fights
versus terry silver have proven that mr
miyagi is still the biggest badass that
ever would ever lived i mean that guy
literally took one hit in all three or
all four karate kid films he only got
one hit on him and that was when he
wasn't looking and karate get part two
so
i mean granted you know chosen and
daniel were
more on the drunk side when they were
fighting terry silver but still i mean
like terry crease not nobody could get a
single hit on him and on mr miyagi so
well i think what they did with the
fights to escalate the danger was they
they trick
they tried triggering the audience into
thinking that crease is dead
which gives this element that is which
gives a a a a presence of life and death
yeah for sure so
definitely you you get like the actual
danger of stakes
but it would be nice to actually kill
off character yeah i know i know
terry silver will get shanked in prison
yeah no i mean you thought maybe for a
second like wow they killed crease and
chosen possibly wow well really it's uh
the the girl from korea
i mean she might carry on the legacy
here and wow against me
i was curious because i love that they
had
danny actually use the things terry
taught him to take him down and i think
she could see you know the techniques of
her lineage within that and it's
probably like the hell you're going to
bring my techniques you know my family's
techniques to the world stage so i could
see that being a thing
her and her anime gang i mean terry was
trying to apply the techniques too it
was just failing bad yeah anyway guys
we did it we watched all of cobra kai we
are caught up with the show you can now
stop bothering us
even though we binged it you could still
follow
us
thank you for being here thank you
andrew for pointing out every easter egg
and only missing like 30. yeah i only
missed like we'll make a supplementary
video at the end of the year when you've
counted them you better do a better job
next time on your fifth watch because um
you were the thinnest device i know if
you were on jaby kawaii's channel i
wouldn't have missed a thing you would
have missed a beat i know you i wouldn't
have fallen asleep i wouldn't have
missed a thing no you would have been
asleep but you would have still caught
all the easter eggs that's true that's
true that's true you would have given it
your a plus game and here solid c minus
all right at least it's a passing grid
i'll take it is it is it a passing grade
are you passing with pride abc i'm in
the top three back to school 1986.
alan meter
oh and uh johnny lawrence william zapko
was in that film too oh hey
j law
i met william zapko
really a nice guy no i didn't meet him
well you should i'm sure he's a nice guy
i've never even seen any of the cobra
kai cast in person oh
me neither i feel like we should have
had an opportunity by now considering
they shoot what looks like two miles
away
for like they're literally two minutes i
should have walked into one of their
frames by accident yeah i should have
seen other star wagons built
that must be for cobra guy
the amount of time so much i like that
rosita apartments establishing shot i'm
like i've literally walked right i might
have been in that complex before yeah
um anyway guys next season final season
you will we'll get there we'll get there
thank you for being here
subscribe click that bell who's the
lucky patron
david gandy d gand
we have looked up your name on urban
dictionary here's what it is david is
the greatest man you'll ever have the
privilege to know
that he is he's one of the greatest
people we've ever known he's the epitome
of a gentleman and he is the most
charismatic person you'll ever meet you
can vouch he's a little shy but you know
once you get to know david
he's got a gentleness about him a warmth
some might say a david has a big heart
and he is very compassionate that's a
gibbon he loves animals especially ducks
he's got a whole farm there in his
backyard quacking dave quack and dave is
what we call him that's right david is
sometimes shy oh yeah and he is very
adorable when he blushes shucks what do
you always say about david you want to
pinch his cheeks lush and quacking david
if you found yourself a david you better
cuff him while you can he's dangerous
david has many men or women vying for
his attention but he is very very loyal
he'll never run out on you he's been
here forever even when he doesn't want
to be david's have so much potential and
ambition oh yeah this guy has
so many gifts david's intellect is
unmatched which is true i mean the
amount that you know the wisdom that
you've imparted on us over time david's
will create great lives for themselves
and their families
he is a caretaker i mean that's a
hundred percent the truth helped create
a great life for us david will make the
best husband and he will never let you
down loyalist
he will also make a great father and he
will do anything for his children
including murdering those ducks oh
david has the most wonderful energy that
is contagious to others he makes people
smile very easily and he has the purest
of souls super spreader dave check this
out a david is very attractive and very
good in bed
makes a duck's watch
and we'll always listen to your desires
and needs
oh yeah he's a pleasure king
david always pleases his partners
emotionally and physically
he is a gorgeous human being
david should always be cherished in love
david deserves the world and whoever
this david is that wrote this clearly
needs some help he's clearly in love
with themselves love me please
i am so great you guys just need to see
it so you can only see the qualities i
possess guys
but david you are these qualities so
thank you for being the great david that
is
[Music]